false impression that you would actually
hear from rob gronkowski we don't have
the sound
i guess i can read that you lie or you
like a lie i can read it like i'm rob
gronkowski okay let me hear your rob
gronkowski voice
jules was an unbelievable player and he
literally gives it
his all for his teammates i just wish
the best for julian to heal up
obviously in his life i can't do it that
sucks
i thought that was really good i thought
it was good i liked it
so so what he says is i'm hoping he
heals up i want the best for him i've
been in that situation before
i believe i believe if julian truly
heals up whatever's hurting on him and
he fully heals and feels good i think
he'll be back
i don't see why he wouldn't be back
eventually
maybe a year or two away remember
remember when
when what was that two years ago we cast
him
in a reboot of the terminator and i
actually counted the number of lines
that arnold schwarzenegger had in the
original
yes and we concluded that gronk could
pull it off right it was 17 i think
i'll be back in 69 minutes
you're on a roll today i love it
[Laughter]
anyway anyway anyway pay no attention to
that man behind the curtain
despite everything julian edelman says
one of his former teammates rob
gronkowski continues to be convinced
he'll be back
well i i mean you know again i'm not
gonna buy it right now just from the
things i do know
and the status of julian edelman's body
like it doesn't sound like this is
something where it's like around the
corner and he might heal up
and i understand there's going to be
speculation about this all year long
because of brady and gronk and
everything like that
you know but man these are two peas in a
pod it's
you know even though they're two
different bodies and kind of an approach
to life
there was a common like gronkowski
edelman
psychoness obsessiveness about football
and being all in and playing no matter
what and that's what the bond with that
patriots team is
and was they had so many of those guys
that's where the great scouting of new
england and bill belichick came into
came in handy they built guys that you
know weren't hostages volunteers as they
say
loved the game always wanted to be there
oh what i have a
bad badly hurt ankles so what i'll try
to play this week the hell with it
uh so that's where probably gronk can't
really believe that julian's gonna gonna
walk away here
during the draft-a-thon that unfolded
during the draft coverage itself i still
understand why they do that during the
draft why not do it monday
tuesday wednesday before the draft
because who's really watching the online
draft-a-thon while the draft is on
anyway that's just my own
you know unsolicited thoughts
programming
suggestion for the folks at nfl media
brady possibly after having a belt or
two of avocado tequila said we know
julian didn't retire let's be honest
he's just too scared to tell bill
he wants to come to tampa i love that i
didn't see that that was
that was the joke from tom no you didn't
work that well you did work that friday
and you still didn't see it but anyway
that was the joke from tom brady
and and julian edelman played along with
it but eventually edelman made it clear
he's done
and look you can't move foxborough
forever merchandise if you leave the
door cracked open or
maybe back right so it's in his business
interest julianelleman.com
foxboro forever registered trademark i
have a feeling
not quite selling as briskly as he would
have thought but uh
once you sell all your foxboro forever
gear then you can then you can be tampa
bay bound
yeah uh yeah i guess so uh i i you know
i i don't know i don't this is one where
i don't get or see this happening
i don't either but but we can't hear
saying it over and over oh i know
gronk's not going to give
it up i mean he's not but but you're
right you know
edelman i think this is this is an issue
that he had been dealing with the last
two years
and even brady's last year in new
england he limped to the finish line and
made that season happen
and it was a lot of work i think to get
ready for the year last year and of
course it finally just fell apart to
where he
feels like he can't do it anymore so
we'll see i mean it'd be awesome
if it came november and all of a sudden
he's signing with tampa bay and we got
something to talk about like that
i'd love that that that's for sure we
spent
all of the 2019 season yeah
wondering when rob gronkowski
was going to return to the patriots and
there was a specific deadline if you're
on the reserve retired list where you
have to
get off of it once and for all and come
back with edelman who was cut by the
patriots
there's no point in late november early
december he can sign with anyone anytime
up to and including super bowl week he
could sign with a team
so he's a free agent he's available
whether it's this year whether it's next
year whether it's the year after it's
something we just have to keep an eye on
and we've seen it before guys will say
with 100
certainty that something's going to
happen and then the exact opposite
eventually happens and and
what what are we going to do oh you lied
or oh you
we just go with it when it happens yeah
we have to keep an eye on it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports